Stéphane Le Foll le ministre de
l'Agriculture et l'invité de Preuves par
3 bonsoir et merci d'être avec nous
cette année a été celle de votre envol
selon le même libre vous êtes passé de
l'anonymat ou presque au statut de
ministre donc responsabilité d'ailleurs
que vous vous étiez préparé à ne pas
obtenir mais ce n'est pas à votre dépend
que François Hollande que vous
accompagnez au plus près depuis 10 ans a
choisi de manifester son ingratitude
qu'il revendique d'ailleurs désormais
comme chef de l'État on parlera de la
présidence Hollande et de vous avec
Perrine Tarneaud tout à l'heure père
interno de Public Sénat et avec Samir
Tounsi de l'Agence France Presse notre
partenaire des premières décisions
prises ou attendues de la place et de
l'avenir du Parti socialiste vous voulez
un PS ranger derrière les couleurs du
hollandisme pour rester au pouvoir 10
ans ainsi que vous l'écrivez dans une
tribune publiée par Le Monde noté que
les téléspectateurs interviennent au
cours de cette émission par le biais de
l'application TV check de notre
partenaire orange d'abord au risque de
vous choquer
en plein drame sociale est-ce que le
volailler doux mérite d'être sauvé vous
défendez un élevage de qualité d'où ne
fait cuisiner des poulets de selon le
critique gastronomique du Monde 2 qui
pose cette question sacrilaire il pose
cette question il oublie une chose c'est
que derrière l'entreprise doux le nom il
y a 4000 salariés 800 à 900 éleveurs et
c'est ça qui m'importe et qui importe
aussi Arnaud Montebourg et
Guillaume Garraud qui travaille avec moi
maintenant c'est de cela dont il s'agit
et en même temps
il s'agit d'une production de poulet de
bas de gamme certes mais qui aujourd'hui
en France voit 40% de notre consommation
est très importée donc les deux réunis
méritent que l'État dans la mesure de ce
qu'il peut faire soit à l'écoute et
surtout cherche à trouver une solution
pour éviter le dépôt ils sont 800 bien
sûr on pense ils sont entraînés dans une
course folle depuis des années par doux
on le sait il produisent au bout de 50
jours des poulets qui n'ont pas de goût
qui n'ont pas d'eau
qui ont pas de goût qui n'ont pas d'eau
qui est des poulets qui avaient des
débouchés à l'exportation jusqu'ici qui
ont bien sûr sûrement il y aura à
réfléchir sur l'évolution de cette
filière on peut pas dire que ça soit
aussi par les poulets de braises et les
poulets légers
c'est un poulet qui coûte plus cher que
tout le monde et ça je vais le dire ce
soir de manière très claire aujourd'hui
il y a de plus en plus de Français qui
n'ont pas accès quotidiennement à la
nourriture pas parce qu'ils ne veulent
pas parce qu'ils ne peuvent pas c'est
comme la question de la santé et donc on
a un problème dans une crise comme on
travaille que nous traversons avec le
chômage que nous connaissons aujourd'hui
on a un problème d'accès à la nourriture
donc on ne peut pas considérer que tout
le monde doit manger du poulet de Bresse
malheureusement malheureusement et il y
a en France en plus des gens qui
consomment du poulet mais pas rôti pas
complet ça reste d'ailleurs une
spécificité française
au modèle du repas français mais au-delà
de ça il y a aussi des gens qui
consomment du poulet autrement les
cuisses des ailes ou qui consomment du
poulet dans différents produits donc on
est bien obligé de répondre à cette
demande aujourd'hui les syndicats du
volley-doo craignent la casse sociale et
le dépeçage de l'entreprise ils auront
les deux non je pense qu'aujourd'hui
malgré le fait que l'offre qui a été
faite aujourd'hui il y en aura peut-être
d'autres puisque le tribunal n'a pas
encore décidé il y a des reprises qui
sont proposées elles sont pas
suffisantes on doit travailler pour
améliorer en particulier au niveau
social ce qui est proposé aujourd'hui
c'est tout le débat que nous pouvons
avoir et c'est le débat que nous aurons
dans les semaines dans les jours qui
viennent mais on peut pas dire qu'il y
ait aucune possibilité de pérenniser une
grande partie de l'activité une grande
ça c'est déjà acté maintenant il faut
qu'on progresse est-ce que le patriarche
Charles duc à 75 ans devra rendre des
comptes mais écoutez le patriarche a
celui qui a piloté et dirigé cette
entreprise pendant des années il y a eu
la phase d'expansion et puis il y a eu
après des phases catastrophiques de
choix stratégiques qui remettent en
cause aujourd'hui la viabilité et la
pérennité de l'ensemble de l'outil il a
fait des investissements au Brésil
inconsidérés et aujourd'hui il y a une
dette de plus de 300 millions d'euros
qui pèse sur cette entreprise et qui
pèse sur lui quand il les rend déjà à
travers
la situation dans laquelle il se trouve
la difficulté la proposition qui est
faite c'est une reprise mais pas avec
Charles Dhou
relancer cette activité il y aura une
difficulté à ce que on reste dans un
périmètre qui soit décidé par Charles de
Gaulle donc l'avenir du volailleuse se
fera sans charlebou voilà ce que vous se
fait avec l'objectif de pérenniser
l'activité les salariés et surtout venez
producteurs de volaille alors vous
connaissez bien votre secteur
ministériel Stéphane Lefel vous l'avez
suivi comme député européen est-ce que
vous le voyez comme un secteur
industriel il y a les deux c'est un
secteur qui comporte une diversité très
grande à la fois des circuits courts la
production agricole d'abord donc
l'agriculture secteur primaire on a
oublié ça dans notre vocabulaire et ça
existe et c'est important j'entends bien
défendre ce secteur primaire et puis ce
secteur primaire il a aussi un secteur
secondaire c'est ce qu'on appelle
l'industrie agroalimentaire qui a
diverses formes il y a des petits de
transformation il y a des circuits
courts il y a des circuits moyens et
puis il y a de la grande industrie donc
l'état à la fois dans le domaine du
primaire l'économie et le secteur
primaire et aussi dans le domaine du
secteur secondaire donc vous vous êtes
confronté à différents segments du
marché j'ai envie de dire est-ce que
vous êtes confronté à des lobbies dans
votre activité professionnelle
ministérielle j'ai envie de dire plutôt
j'ai vu que vous ayez reçu des cadeaux
de votre nomination vous voyez que j'ai
renvoyé au domaine donc
foulards
je sais pas ce que je m'en suis pas
préoccupé j'ai renvoyé tout ça au
domaine donc ceux qui veulent me séduire
des propositions et ces propositions
elles portent sur des grands sujets
l'avenir de l'agriculture française la
prise en compte de l'environnement
l'avenir de l'industrie agroalimentaire
et de la transformation de l'ensemble
des produits et puis la pérennité de
l'agriculture et des agriculteurs sur
l'ensemble du territoire cela sont reçu
les discussions sont faites après il y a
des gens qui défendent des intérêts vous
pensez bien que dans tous les domaines
des gens défendent des intérêts la
question du Cruiser au sr décision prise
et bien vous avez vu que l'entreprise
qui commercialise se produit
tout de suite voilà n'est pas contente
il le fait savoir
malgré ces réticences et résistances de
certains lobbies industriels j'en ai
fait la preuve est-ce que vous êtes
prêts
scientifiques j'avais eu à la fois ce
qui avait été produit par la Révolution
et ensuite la vie qui avait été donnée
par l'ancêtre sur cette base là je n'ai
pas hésité
divergent sauf que là elle a validé
l'étude qui avait prouvé que cette
famille de molécules en particulier pour
le colza avait des conséquences très
importantes et très négatives sur la
capacité des abeilles à retourner à la
rue d'accord mais là on prend une
décision vous prenez une décision il y
en aura d'autres parce que par exemple
voyager un peu partout en France une
mission d'information sur les pesticides
qui donc multiplient les visites sur les
terrains est-ce que vous allez
éventuellement interdire d'autres
pesticides demain mais ça va dépendre de
l'évaluation de la nocivité de ces
pesticides moi le principe plutôt large
qui va être et qui va me guider c'est
comment je fais pour changer les modèles
de production et limiter le recours
pesticides de la même manière qu'aux
herbicides c'est un enjeu non pas
simplement un enjeu environnemental bien
sûr et c'est en même temps un enjeu
économique une question c'est ça le
débat simplement d'interdire très simple
votre prédécesseur au ministère de
l'Agriculture avait autorisé le retour
des épandages par avion ça n'était pas
autorisé dans le Grenelle de
l'environnement est-ce que là vous allez
poursuivre dans votre dans cette journée
ou pas
il y a des problèmes aussi qui sont liés
spécifiquement ça ne peut être que par
dérogation sur un problème
ponctuels liées à une maladie qui se
développe rapidement et sur lequel il
faut qu'il y ait une décision qui soit
prise ça ne peut être que dans ce cas-là
on doit sortir de cette logique comment
dirais-je qui a consisté à utiliser les
produits chimiques d'une manière massive
continue et donc il y aura des
dérogations il y a des problèmes et
quand je n'ai pas l'alternative c'est
difficile de faire autrement d'accord
bon donc c'est un recul par rapport au
Grenelle de l'environnement c'est pas un
recul par rapport au droit de
l'environnement puisque vous savez très
bien que dans ce Grenelle avait été
prévu la règle elle ne souffre que de
dérogation dans des cas ultime donc je
reste sur cette logique là et toute la
question qui posait c'est pas simplement
dire je vais interdire les épandages
quand il y a un gros problème c'est de
je vous le répète changer les modèles de
production pour éviter le moins possible
d'avoir recours à la chimie et le plus
possible alors la nature est-ce que les
OGM peuvent être une alternative aux
pesticides aux produits phytosanitaires
selon votre peureux face à ces
organismes génétiquement modifier deux
types de GM aujourd'hui qui sont mis sur
le marché des OGM qui résistent à des
herbicides
un
OGM une plante un maïs en l'occurrence
il résiste à un herbicide spécifique
vous sulfactez l'herbicides il reste
rien que la plante qui résiste premier
OGM deuxième c'est les OGM qui
produisent eux-mêmes des pesticides et
ça ça me convient pas du tout d'accord
ça ne me convient pas du tout et qu'on
vient pas me raconter qu'avec ce genre
d'évolution on va changer et faire
évoluer les choses non il y a bien
d'autres techniques d'autres modèles de
production qui permettent de faire
beaucoup mieux sans avoir recours à ce
type de gemmes c'est pas pour autant
d'ailleurs qu'ensuite sur des cautions
d'évolution génétique pour que les
plantes améliorent en particulier un
certain nombre de qualités qui peuvent
être recherchés résistance au stress
cythique je prenais l'état de la
betterave sur un peu plus de sucre dans
la betterave ça c'est des évolutions qui
peuvent être intéressantes et qui dans
le cadre d'un développement dans la
nature ne pose pas de problème là on a
quand même des OGM qui sont résistants à
certains herbicides on a aujourd'hui aux
États-Unis des plantes qui deviennent
résistantes elles-mêmes à ses herbicides
et donc il y a un problème ensuite pour
la nature de manière et surtout pour les
productions agricoles à propos de la
nature est-ce que vous êtes derrière les
éleveurs de Haute-Savoie ou des Vosges
qui perdent de leur troupeau en ce
moment en raison de la présence de loups
on parle même de meute dans les Vosges
aujourd'hui j'ai un problème de
cohabitation sérieux qu'il faudra
mais mon avis comme ministre il y a des
prédateurs qui sont arrivés il y a des
solutions on est radicaux et je réponds
à la question est-ce que c'est ça la
solution non je pense qu'il faut qu'on
trouve des voies et des moyens mais je
comprends aussi en même temps que des
éleveurs aujourd'hui trouvent que dans
les conditions actuelles et bien c'est
payé cher la présence des prédateurs
donc il faut qu'on trouve des voies et
des moyens pour faire évoluer les choses
et aujourd'hui on en est pas encore là
malheureusement on a parlé des lobbies
est-ce que pour vous la puissante
effetsea est un lobby non c'est un grand
syndicat qui défend les intérêts de son
syndicat je veux pas trahir là quoi que
ce soit de la même manière que la
Confédération paysanne défend un certain
type d'agriculture et un
pour une plus grande diversité des
propositions j'ai fait déjà des
propositions de réformes dans le cadre
des élections professionnelles et des
chambres d'agriculture pour en
particulier favoriser la
représentativité au niveau régional
assurer aussi une majorité pour pouvoir
gouverner les Chambres d'agriculture
mais on avance et je continuerai à faire
des positions dans ce domaine alors je
note que dans la situation économique si
difficile que nous traversons les
agriculteurs voient leurs revenus
augmenter vous allez vous même devoir
accompagner la réforme de la Politique
Agricole Commune vous avez annoncé
également une loi cadre de l'agriculture
sur l'agriculture ce sont pour l'an
prochain on n'a pas compris à quoi
servait auprès de vous Guillaume Garraud
donc communiste délégué à
l'agroalimentaire oui vous l'avez cité
il y a un instant mais on s'est dit il
est là uniquement pour apaiser la colère
de Ségolène Royal
député et qui aujourd'hui et demain va
suivre toute la question posée par le
groupe Doux en particulier qui va aussi
ce qu'on avait anticipé prévu et c'est
lui qui en aura toute la charge des
grandes tables rondes sur l'avenir de
l'industrie et bien sûr dans ce domaine
là il y a un rôle et ça me permettra moi
de me concentrer sur une grande question
qu'il est la réforme de la Politique
Agricole Commune très bien allez le
gouvernement est à l'oeuvre dans un
contexte budgétaire difficile vous avez
reçu votre lettre de cadrage comme l'on
dit alors quel est le montant des
économies à réaliser pour vous quelles
sont les conséquences dans la gestion du
ministère de l'Agriculture vous allez
pouvoir nous le dire mais d'abord avant
d'accueillir Samir Tounsi de l'Agence
Française qui nous attend l'enquête de
Marie brémo
on promet l'ouverture de poste dans
l'enseignement agricole les craintes
persistent au vu d'une réalité dégradée
on assiste à des fermetures de classe à
des fermetures y compris des fois ou à
des regroupements de d'établissements ou
alors on pousse effectivement les jeunes
soit aller vers l'enseignement privé ou
vers l'apprentissage au-delà des
effectifs il faudra au ministre arbitrer
les dépenses d'intervention ce qui
signifie externaliser privatiser
certaines missions dans le viseur du
ministère le contrôle sanitaire des
abattoirs on envisage j'ai cru
comprendre de supprimer ces contrôleurs
pour y mettre des salariés des abattoirs
par exemple bien entendu il y a des
risques alimentaires derrière ces
gens-là sont formés ils sont en
sermentés ils ont mettre un salarié
qu'un pouvoir hiérarchique au-dessus de
lui bien entendu c'est pas la même chose
de nombreuses pistes d'économies peuvent
être envisagés suppression de certains
opérateurs ces établissements publics
qui dépendent du ministère
transfert des compétences aux
collectivités locales les syndicats ont
eux de nombreuses doléances à exposer au
ministre lors des négociations en
interne qui ont lieu tout au long du
mois de juillet
de l'agence avec nous bonsoir Samir vos
questions au ministre de l'Agriculture
bonsoir c'est folle la rigueur un mot
tabou pour un gouvernement de gauche non
mais personne n'a caché pendant cette
campagne présidentielle qu'il allait
qu'il allait être nécessaire d'avoir de
faire des efforts compte tenu de la
situation économique qu'on connaissait
et compte tenu de ce qu'on a pu mesurer
et trouver en arrivant personne n'a dit
autre chose donc il s'agit d'être
conforme aux objectifs qu'on s'est fixés
à la fois de réduction des déficits
budgétaires quatre et demi cette année
trois l'année prochaine pour un objectif
de zéro en 2017 c'est ça qui reste la
ligne donc on a besoin de rester
conforme aux engagements qui ont été
pris par le Président de la République
alors on appelle ça de la rigueur mais
c'est une gestion
rigoureuse d'un budget dont on sait
aujourd'hui ne pas pouvoir
étendre le périmètre sans risque si on
veut retrouver de l'indépendance et de
la souveraineté face au marché financier
il faut qu'on réduise nos déficit
budgétaire et il faut qu'on évite de
faire exploser la dette vous voyez ici
ce qui peut se passer dans d'autres pays
on a intérêt d'être extrêmement vigilant
donc c'est simplement une question de
bonne gestion je voudrais revenir sur
une question qui qui concerne
directement votre activité de mise
l'agriculture une question un peu
technique qui s'appelle la
contractualisation depuis la loi de
modernisation de l'agriculture de votre
prédécesseur les producteurs et les
industriels qui leur achètent leurs
produits le lait doivent passer un
contrat vous savez que les producteurs
laitiers notamment j'ai la lettre d'un
producteur laitier du Maine-et-Loire
sous les yeux qui rappelle que dans la
filière laitière 53% de la marge et
faites par les industriels et 30% par la
grande distribution ce qui explique la
détresse du monde agricole aujourd'hui
et il ajoute à propos de ces fameux
contrats pourquoi un pas de 5 ans sans
prix vous savez qu'il n'y a pas de prix
plancher dans ces contrats qu'est-ce que
vous pouvez répondre à cette agriculteur
dans une lettre qui vous était adressée
d'abord vous savez oui je sais et je
vais avoir un rapport qui va être donné
et délivré le 13 juillet c'est à dire
vendredi que j'ai demandé pour faire le
point sur cette contractualisation
laitière il faut que vous sachiez qu'il
y a des contrats qui sont différents
selon les industriels aujourd'hui et
qu'il était nécessaire pour le ministre
de l'Agriculture de faire le point quels
sont les objectifs à partir de là que je
vais chercher à poursuivre il y en a
deux majeurs le premier c'est de
permettre aux agriculteurs producteurs
laitiers de pouvoir s'organiser c'est la
question des groupements qui peuvent
négocier avec les transformateurs ce qui
donne plus de poids aux producteurs par
rapport aux transformateurs et la
deuxième question qui était dans le
paquet d'ailleurs européen que j'avais
moi-même négocié à l'époque c'est de
tenir compte de la question des prix il
y a dans certains contrats aujourd'hui
aucun prix de fixé c'est négocié
mensuellement l'objectif que je vais
essayer de mettre en oeuvre c'est
d'avoir une négociation qui pourrait
prendre en compte une durée de prix plus
longue et dans le paquet européen le
fameux packley qui avait été adopté on
avait une durée de 6 mois 6 mois
d'accord donc vous pouvez pour être pour
être clair vous pourriez garantir aux
producteurs laitiers pour qui c'est une
question vraiment cruciale que dans
quelques mois ils auraient ils
passeraient des contrats avec par
exemple Lactalis pour pas le nommer qui
prévoirait
que je veux un prix pour 6 mois
de cet été le 13 juillet je reçois le
rapport qui va faire le point sur
l'ensemble des contrats et je vous le
dis il y en a qui sont différents des
uns des autres donc il y a des clauses
de prix par exemple qui ont été prévues
par certains transformateurs et pas par
d'autres donc je vais faire le point je
rendrai public ce rapport pour que ça
soit transparent et à partir de là
j'engagerai une négociation
purement politique vous envisagez
toujours d'étendre la politique de
contractualisation à la filière viande
alors au vu de ce que je vais avoir à
mettre en œuvre au niveau de la
contractualisation laitière j'ai déjà
engagé quelques discussions la prise de
contact avec un certain nombre de
filières pour savoir si ça les
intéressait dans quelle mesure ça les
intéresser et ce que j'ai dit là est-ce
que je viens d'annoncer ou enfin de dire
qu'elle est ma logique ça intéresse donc
au niveau des interprofessions en
particulier Bouvines ça peut intéresser
donc je vais faire le point sur le lait
je vais essayer et d'engager la
négociation sur les bases que j'ai
évoquées et après il est possible qu'on
détende cette contractualisation avec un
objectif simple c'est de permettre aux
producteur d'être organisé d'avoir des
filières organisées de ne pas remettre
en cause l'équilibre économique des
transformateurs mais de faire en sorte
que les producteurs soient aussi un peu
entendus très bien nouvelle règle du jeu
vous avez été pendant des années le
directeur de cabinet de François
Hollande premier secrétaire du Parti
socialiste avant d'être 11 ans 11 ans
vous avez été vous avez occupé ce rôle
quand le Parti socialiste quand Lionel
Jospin était premier ministre une
question là vous avez encore plus de
pouvoir à quoi sert un parti de gauche
quand quand il a l'exécutif quand il a
le quand il a les plus grandes villes et
enfin on va vers un parti qui qui semble
aller peu à peu vers
une politique de parties croupion voilà
alors pour vous répondre ayant vécu les
deux périodes celles d'un parti dans la
majorité avec un premier ministre et
celle d'un parti dans l'opposition un
parti dans la majorité d'abord il a des
échéances électorales majeurs à préparer
il y en aura des 2014 donc le Parti
socialiste n'est pas sans travail il y a
là l'occasion de justifier l'existence
d'un grand parti comme le deuxième point
un grand parti tant la majorité est un
parti nécessaire pour le débat
démocratique il ne peut pas y avoir
uniquement à débat démocratique entre
gouvernement qui s'adresse aux Français
et un gouvernement qui s'adresserait
uniquement à l'opposition il doit y
avoir un parti majoritaire qui assume un
rôle démocratique dans le débat qui fixe
une identité politique c'est ce que j'ai
dit aujourd'hui qui donne une lecture
politique de la politique qui est
conduite et qui l'assume comme une
identité politique dans le débat
démocratique donc c'est très important
le parti mais bien sûr il nous
traversera toujours elle est toujours
des débats il y en aura des débats vous
nous dites ça aujourd'hui il y a trois
jours vous souhaitiez quasiment une
motion unique au congrès de toi
mais tout en disant ça vous souhaitez
une motion largeur rassemblement quasi
unique au congrès de tout bien sûr
je pense que il y a besoin devant les
Français de se rassembler aujourd'hui
personne ne comprendrait qu'on s'engage
après une victoire comme celle que nous
venons de vivre dans les difficultés qui
sont les nôtres dans un débat général on
referait les congrès qu'on a connu ça a
beaucoup de sel pour les journalistes
qui font les commentaires mais je crois
que devant les Français c'est pas ça
qu'ils attendent premier point deuxième
point quelle
identité politique c'est ça que j'ai
voulu dire c'est ça qui est important
c'est pas simplement le rassemblement
pour le rassemblement c'est nécessaire
mais c'est pas suffisant il faut qu'il y
ait une ligne politique vous avez
conquis le pouvoir sans lignes politique
sans identité
il y aura des débats on sait très bien
que le Parti socialiste connais cette
diversité aujourd'hui cette victoire
nécessite qu'on tire les leçons de cette
victoire sur quoi c'est appuyé François
Hollande pour gagner pourquoi il a
rencontré les Français 5 points clés
rapidement oui rapidement 5 points clés
il y a la question européenne majeure on
est à partir européen on doit assumer
cet engagement on va être un parti
décentralisateur il y aura une grande
boîte décentralisation je pense que
l'identité des socialistes aujourd'hui
c'est de le revendiquer de manière
claire on est un parti avec François
Hollande qui a défini l'idée du pacte
productif c'est-à-dire le fait qu'on
passe d'une économie financière à une
économie d'investissement et de
production c'est nouveau et je le lis
cette question de la production à la
question de l'écologie il y a une
transition écologique à assurer et puis
on a un parti sur la jeunesse et
l'éducation qui est un enjeu essentiel
en écrit il y a la République
c'est-à-dire le fait que moi j'ai
constaté après la victoire de François
Hollande l'idée que il y avait un
apaisement et que les gens étaient très
satisfaits du fait on n'est plus là pour
stigmatiser et diviser par tes
socialiste alors ça va être le parti
hollandiste non je pense que je tire des
conclusions politiques de ce qui s'est
passé dans la dans la tribune que vous
publiez dans le monde cet après-midi
vous rendez un hommage appuyé à Martine
Aubry vous souhaitez qu'elle remplit la
tête du Parti socialiste moi ce que j'ai
voulu dire cet après-midi c'est que 1 il
fallait assumer ses responsabilités
devant les Français et on peut pas se
diviser pour se diviser ou pour le
plaisir d'avoir des débats entre nous
pour des postures internes 2 j'ai dit
qu'il fallait définir une
identité politique elle est liée à la
victoire de François Hollande ça me
paraît quand même l'essentiel et
troisième point sur le reste la
discussion est ouverte alors je répète
je reprends ma question parce que je
crois que j'ai pas eu de réponse
est-ce que vous souhaitez que Marine que
Martine que Martine Aubry rempile à la
tête du Parti Social je l'ai dit j'étais
pas forcément favorable au primaire au
départ et je trouve que ça a été une
réussite donc je vais pas non plus faire
comme si je vais pas à saluer ce qui
s'était passé on le sait tous c'est un
grand moment démocratique à partir de là
moi la question que je pose sur la table
ce que j'évoque c'est ce que je vous ai
dit pour ce qui est de savoir si Martine
Aubry doit ou pas rester c'est à elle de
le dire
c'était un coup politique de maître de
nommé Benoît Hamon au gouvernement
alors c'est des bonnes des âmes
charitables aux parties socialiste dit
qu'il est le secrétaire d'État au ticket
resto c'était un coup de maître de le
nommer à ce poste là pour étouffer la
gauche du parti pour museler la gauche
du parti à l'Assemblée
sociale et solidaire j'ai encore vu des
coopératives et des coopérateurs au
niveau agricole et des mutualistes je
vous le dis quand même c'est une
économie qui compte deuxièmement sur
tout ce qui va être la politique de
l'emploi il y a un enjeu majeur dans
cette économie donc le rôle de Benoît
mon que je vais voir et on va discuter
de tout ça et pas simplement sur les
tickets restaurants il est bien au-delà
sur comment on utilise cette économie
sociale et solidaire pour développer
l'emploi parce que c'est quand même le
sujet majeur le deuxième le deuxième
point ce gouvernement a rassemblé tous
ceux qui pendant la campagne de François
Hollande ce sont engagés dans cette
campagne et ont soutenu François donc
vous risquez pas de laisser le monopole
de la
de la contestation à la gauche de la
gauche et à la rue
il y a toujours un risque quand on est
au responsabilités c'est pour ça qu'il
faut être le plus clair et le plus net
possible à la fois sur les objectifs et
les enjeux sur les perspectives qu'on
donne et sur une identité politique
qu'on représente si on commence à
vouloir jouer tous les tableaux à ce
moment-là c'est vrai qu'on donnera un
espace à ceux qui peuvent contester je
comprends c'est pas facile mais on l'a
dit et on doit l'assumer mais en même
temps doit se projeter c'est tout
l'enjeu de ce congrès et c'est tout
l'enjeu de ce qui est engagé par le
gouvernement de Jean-Marc Ayrault je
prends la conférence sociale nouveauté
quand même démocratie sociale pour la
première fois c'est à saluer et moi je
le salue vous comprendriez qu'une partie
du groupe socialiste s'abstiennent sur
leur ratification du du paquet européen
qui viendra quand si ça vient à
l'Assemblée mais quand ça viendra devant
le Parlement
moi je pense qu'il y a un engagement
européen je l'ai dit et qui a eu un
choix fait par François Hollande qui a
été concrétisé il avait dit il ne peut
pas y avoir de traiter d'austérité sans
croissance et sans engagement sur la
croissance et
l'investissement
vous l'avez vu toute la première les
premières semaines se débat a été porté
il y a eu un changement de ton à
l'échelle de l'Europe on a un sommet qui
a eu lieu qui a tiré des conclusions je
pense que ces conclusions sont très
importantes il y a un changement de
ligne à l'échelle de temps
à ce qui a été l'engagement de François
Hollande on est dans une position où la
France est le président de la République
ont modifié et changé la ligne qui était
celle précédemment
posée sur la table au niveau européen
c'est ça qui compte et c'est ça l'enjeu
majeur vous avez parlé de la conférence
sociale il y a un thème qui s'impose
aujourd'hui qui s'est imposé d'ailleurs
le chef de l'État en en parlait il en
parlait moins durant la campagne
présidentielle c'est la quoi
productivité des entreprises allégées le
coût du travail il en a pas franchement
parlé pendant sa campagne
reconnaissez-le et donc le chantier
pacte productif a été pratiquement les
trois grands thèmes qui avaient été
déposés par François Hollande à Lorient
au mois de juin 2009 pour alléger le
coup du travail qui est donc est un
problème c'est reconnu et si vous ne
voulez pas de la TVA il vous reste la
CSG
la question de des cotisations qui est
posée c'est à dire ce qu'on appelle les
cotisations sociales et l'assiette de
ces cotisations c'est une question qui
est posée c'est à dire que aujourd'hui
ça pèse sur le coup du travail et il y a
des pistes sur lequel on a des
réflexions à avoir c'est ce qu'a proposé
qui a une base plus large la valeur
ajoutée dans les entreprises
peu différent et puis aussi peut-être ça
avait été évoqué les questions de taxes
sur le carbone
François Hollande va nous parler le 14
juillet
c'est une tradition républicaine c'est
un usage rassuré
de la République ce qu'il doit dire il
dira ce qu'il a envie de dire
à l'écart de la scène nationale
puisqu'il était pris par les rendez-vous
européens
européen internationaux qui concernaient
les Français la question de l'Europe pas
des finition elle était très importante
mais là une déclaration de politique
générale il y a un cadre qui a été fixé
il y a une grande conférence sur la
démocratie sociale qui a été engagée il
a fait un très beau discours d'ailleurs
au Conseil économique et social et
environnemental donc je pense qu'il a de
quoi sur ces grands sujets là s'adresser
aux Français
en attendant le 14 juillet tous ensemble
merci
Samia Perrine ternote Public Sénat
arrive donc juste après cette enquête
sur vous Stéphane le fun c'est craignez
timbre nuit
longtemps Stéphane lefal a officié dans
l'ombre de François Hollande et lui
député européen en 2004 il est resté son
directeur de cabinet en parallèle
impossible de mettre fin à ce duo qui se
connaît depuis longtemps très longtemps
Stéphane a travaillé avec François
pendant 17 ans 17 ans donc c'est pas
rien du rafl
exible dans la réputation de porte
flingue un apparaît chic dit-on toujours
au service de François Hollande la
fidélité
c'est notre point commun déjà à la base
tout comme ça aussi Stéphane Le folle a
vécu la traversée du désert de François
Hollande et dès 2008 c'est lui le pilier
de ses irréductibles qui croient en
impossible aujourd'hui le voilà
récompensé nommé à la tête du ministère
de l'agriculture dont il est spécialiste
et même dans l'opposition on reconnaît
sa compétence dans le casting
gouvernemental peut avoir des doutes sur
les positionnements des uns et des
autres pense qu'il concerne où il est
vraiment une place sur laquelle il a une
autorité qui est qui est reconnue et qui
s'appuie vraiment sur du travail au
cours de ces dernières années et
pourtant le poste a
faillite François Hollande refusant de
mieux traiter ses proches que les autres
place aux autres tendances du PS mais
aussi aux Alliés d'Europe Écologie Les
Verts des alliés qui pourraient poser
problème pour le nouveau ministre de
l'Agriculture le véritable enjeu
finalement il est assez simple c'est de
savoir s'il va être capable de résister
à la pression d'une partie de ses amis
et il faut faire en sorte
également de pas être dans une logique
comment dirais-je
environnementaliste qui considérait que
l'idéal pour la nature c'est qu'elle ne
soit pas cultivée bref l'ancien grognard
de François Hollande trouve aujourd'hui
la lumière et les problèmes qui vont
avec
réputation de portefeuille de François
Hollande qui date de vos longues années
de compagnonnage avec lui au sein du
Parti socialiste c'est vrai que vous
avez longtemps été ce grand type dans le
monde de François Hollande qui avait un
peu au Parti socialiste le rôle du tueur
alors que le premier secrétaire lui
cultivait un peu plus ses rondeurs
j'ai eu par contre une détermination
sans faille à soutenir François Hollande
à le faire dans l'esprit qui était le
sien c'est à dire qu'il y avait aussi à
composer je crois que le Parti
socialiste salut a été reproché
d'ailleurs au moment du congrès de Reims
cette espèce de synthèse d'équilibre
qu'il trouvait toujours et donc moi j'ai
participé à tout ça donc j'étais pas
plus dans une démarche de tueur comme ça
a été dit souvent j'étais là
exécuter des décisions
la preuve c'est que tout le monde s'est
retrouvé à Reims en capacité de pouvoir
briller les postes que chacun pouvait
briller cette image non mais j'ai été à
côté de François Hollande c'est vrai il
y avait eu une formule qui avait été
assez chouette qui était moins violente
que celle que vous utilisez c'était
fado folle et ou si carré que François
Hollande est ronds voilà à l'époque
c'était il y a 4-5 ans
et entier c'est sûr j'ai eu je l'ai dit
une fidélité François Hollande et puis
j'ai une sincérité je suis parti en
étant élu à 23 ans d'un petit village de
256 habitants donc j'ai une carrière qui
est un peu différente après du sport
preuve je sais pas fait ce qu'on peut
faire d'autre et que je respecte mais
j'ai donc cette caractéristique là voilà
vous avez une vie avant d'être un homme
politique et pourtant vous entraînez
aussi une réputation d'apparachique
de cabinet par définition ça laisse
quelques traces et on peut imaginer que
on peut penser que je n'ai rien fait
d'autre bon j'ai fait d'autres choses
mais j'ai été là oui longtemps et donc
ça laisse cette trace là mais je crois
que j'ai su et je sais à la fois assumer
les responsabilités qui ont été les
miennes et en même temps garder bien
d'autres qualités que celles que vous ne
j'espère que
j'ai lu cette définition de votre
relation de François Hollande lui-même
je suis petit il est grand il est très
dur et moi je suis plutôt souple mais
les dures d'apparence sont sensibles et
les souples inflexibles est-ce que c'est
un bon
portraits
déterminé François Hollande il y a
toujours apparu comme quelqu'un qui
était
tout à fait sympathique avenant et c'est
vrai il y a une relation mais il a une
détermination totale la preuve la preuve
et ceux qui ont cru donc une apparence
qui trompe
justement que c'était l'apparence qui
comptait ce sont brûler les doigts pour
certains bref je parvenir sur toute
cette histoire mais en même temps oui
ben grand je sais pas quoi et en même
temps sensible oui sensible comme tout
le monde d'ailleurs je ne crois vous
dites vous voulez pas revenir sur toute
cette histoire de la campagne des
critiques à l'encontre de François
Hollande mais tout le monde
sélectionne mais je les oublie aussi
j'ai pas de mémoire
il a dit aussi vis-à-vis de ses amis
de ses amis
il est il est dans des choix il les fait
par rapport à des enjeux et des
stratégies politiques ça veut dire quand
on est au pouvoir pour atteindre ses
objectifs finalement on a plus d'amis
de garder de l'amitié son entourage dit
aujourd'hui de François Hollande que il
a toutes les qualités de François
Mitterrand sauf la fidélité à ses amis
moi je crois pas c'est plus compliqué
puis vous savez quand on est à la tête
et qu'on arrive comme ça j'ai vu tout je
suis bien placé pour vous dire que c'est
jamais facile et donc je moi je suis pas
là pour faire des des procès et surtout
bon je suis Amandine avec François
Hollande pour savoir aussi que il a
comme d'autres beaucoup de sensibilité
malgré le fait qu'il soit déterminé
c'est quelqu'un de très sensible dont je
ne crois pas du tout à ce qui vient
d'être dit je pense que il garde et
c'est sa force aussi une profonde
humanité on a
donné avec Orange elle leur application
TV check alors il y a des questions qui
nous arrivent des internautes
aujourd'hui ça marche une question
notamment de Caroline vous n'avez pas
peur que François Hollande s'enferme
dans la solitude du pouvoir c'est
toujours une vraie question est-ce que
le pouvoir isole et comment on sort de
l'isolement du pouvoir je pense que
c'est pas oui je crois je crois parce
qu'il a besoin lui d'aller au contact
des gens c'est quelqu'un qui qui aime
bien aller à la recherche et au contact
donc voilà il faut qu'il trouve
ce risque
il va organiser des déplacements il va
assurer une présence je pense que bon
voilà c'est lui qui va choisir mais je
pense que c'est vrai et dans le temps en
particulier il faut faire très attention
à ça des parlementaires socialiste surge
aujourd'hui contre le choix de
Jean-Pierre jouillet pour diriger la
Caisse des Dépôts
très proche de François Hollande mais il
a été aussi un ministre d'ouverture de
Nicolas Sarkozy est-ce qu'on devrait à
ce titre lui barrer la route moi je ne
le crois pas il est aujourd'hui la tête
de la de l'agence de la Coupe du Monde
de l'AMF du contrôle des marchés
financiers donc
je suis en train de chercher j'avais
perdu autorité des marchés financiers
AMF et il exerce cette autorité cette
autorité ou ce dirige cette autorité
avec les compétences qu'on lui connaît
il a pris des positions d'ailleurs sur
les questions financières sur la crise
financière qui n'était pas celle qu'on a
pu entendre de la part d'autres
activités
socialiste des affaires européennes qui
restait un an oui mais au moment où le
bouclier
fiscaliste d'avoir été ministre dans un
gouvernement de Nicolas Sarkozy au
moment où le bouclier fiscal a été créé
au moment où il y avait un ministère de
l'Identité nationale est-ce que vous ça
vous choque qu'il puisse aujourd'hui
je connais bien enfin je connais un peu
Jean-Pierre juillet et je l'ai côtoyé au
Parlement européen à cette époque là je
sais ce qui me disait sur un certain
nombre de sujets que vous évoquez et
d'ailleurs il l'a quitté très vite ce
gouvernement il a été nommé il a
pour il est resté le temps de la
présidence française européenne vous en
souvenez voilà ce qu'il a fait et je
crois pas que dans ces prises de
position quelquefois quelques à quelques
occasions que ce soit il y a eu un
dérapage ou une prise de position qui ne
soit pas conforme aux valeurs que nous
défendons et la Caisse des Dépôts avec
l'enjeu qui a derrière de la banque
publique d'investissement est un enjeu
où il faut quelqu'un qui puisse avoir
les compétences pour guider et diriger
cette crise les députés sénateurs
socialistes critiques vous dites il faut
savoir comprendre et pardonner il faut
savoir comprendre et pardonner
comprendre et pardonner
il faut savoir comprendre il y a des
enjeux majeurs et en particulier cette
caisse des dépôts donc il faut des gens
compétents je ne crois pas que là-dessus
on puisse considérer que Jean-Pierre
Joly n'est pas les compétences donc il a
les compétences j'oublie pas d'ailleurs
parce que ça c'est facile mais il a été
quoi aussi Jean-Pierre juillet
le directeur adjoint de cabinet de
Monsieur
Delore et de Lionel
il a des petites
élus socialistes mais on refuse
et vous avez répondu comprendre et
pardonner
via orange et une question qui nous
arrive de serge Papin qui dirige Système
U serge Papin qui vous demande vous avez
évoqué le souhait de nouveau modèle
productif pour l'agriculture quel serait
alors la place de la grande distribution
dans leur élaboration
aucune place la grande distribution n'a
rien à voir avec les techniques et les
modèles de production agricole il s'agit
d'agronomie il s'agit de techniques de
production donc je vois pas quel est le
rapport la grande distribution distribue
des produits finis transformés très bien
là il s'agit de se poser les questions
pour savoir comment on réussit à assurer
une transition vers la durabilité pour
l'ensemble de l'agriculture s'agit pas
uniquement de dire et de fixer les
objectifs en termes de surface par
exemple pour l'agriculture bio qu'il
faudra développer il s'agit aussi de se
poser la question de la transition
globale de l'agriculture moins de
pesticides moins d'herbicides moins de
consommation énergétique moins d'engrais
minéraux c'est ça l'enjeu et il y a des
modèles aujourd'hui il y a des
techniques qu'il faut développer et
c'est ça
environnementaliste pardon va dominer
c'est pas une logique
environnementaliste c'est une logique
qui consiste à dire que sur les
pesticides comme les herbicides la
chimie on peut faire aussi bien avec
beaucoup moins et ça serait complètement
ridicule de se priver de cet enjeu là
deuxièmement moins vous consommez de
consommation intermédiaire moins vous
avez des risques de polluer et plus vous
êtes capable de dégager je lui rajoute
pour les agriculteurs de la marge brute
à l'état donc il y a à la fois un
intérêt écologique environnemental et
économique c'est l'enjeu du débat que je
vais ouvrir sur ces questions donc
raccourcir les circuits économiques
vous me parlez de modèle de production
c'est à dire les techniques culturelles
comment on produit vous êtes dans un
jardin quand vous faites du jardin vous
bêchez vous semez et vous récolter après
on distribue et on transporte et bien
pour pêcher on peut se passer du béchage
par exemple vous pouvez mettre de la
moutarde vous allégé votre terrain vous
coupez votre moutarde vous pouvez fixer
de l'azote et derrière vous pouvez semer
c'est un changement de technique
culturelle
c'est la réponse à Monsieur Papin en
tous les cas je me sens la grande
distribution pensez bien je me souviens
de la polémique après les attentats
terroristes à Toulouse à la fin du
quinquennat et notamment de la volonté
du Parti socialiste de créer une mission
d'information parlementaire pour
comprendre un peu les zones d'ombres
dans cette affaire là et pourquoi
aujourd'hui vous condamnez la
publication des enregistrements audio du
terrorisme avec son agent traitant alors
que justement elles font apparaître ils
font apparaître ses enregistrements les
fameuses zones d'ombre que vous soutenez
le problème qui a là aujourd'hui c'est
que les victimes parce qu'il faut y
penser ont découvert ces enregistrements
comme tout le monde à la télévision
elles sont les premières concernées on
peut pas faire ça comme ça sans avoir
une discussion sur les enjeux sur le
rôle et sans et les prévenir ou discuter
avec elle c'est ça qui me choque parce
qu'au bout du compte il y a besoin de
là-dessus d'y voir clair il y a un
jugement il y a une enquête qui doit
être faite mais vis-à-vis des victimes
et ça je les 10 je le répète j'ai trouvé
que c'était une manière qui consistait à
dire j'informe tout le monde et je me
préoccupe pas des victimes c'est quand
même elle qui ont subi le plus lourd
préjudice une mise en garde de CSA
c'est-à-dire pas de sanction quoi c'est
juste un petit avertissement ça vous
paraît suffisant mais moi je peux pas
parler à la place je vous dis ce que je
pense je pense que c'était pas bien de
faire ce qui a été fait et de d'annoncer
ça comme ça de le donner au grand public
sans avoir ni prévenu discuter avec les
victimes très bien merci à vous merci
Perrine c'est le dernier preuve par 3 de
la saison on vous souhaite de bonnes
vacances vous reviendrez plus tard on
vous souhaite un très bon été et à très
vite
un homme qui appartient je le sais à
quel trop pays ou qu'elle continent et
qui accepte de donner sa vie pour un
pays dont il n'est pas pour moi c'est le
comble de la négation
français par le sang versé
ou comment une loi a fini par permettre
aux légionnaires blessés au combat
d'acquérir la nationalité française on a
servi à un pays avec des armes et tombe
blessé pour moi ça crée un lien je sais
pas ça ça m'a dit que maintenant c'est
je vais finir ma vie ici
français par le sang versé samedi à 22h
sur Public Sénat
tous les matins à 8h15 Guillaume Durand
et Gilles Leclerc reçoivent une
personnalité politique dans en route
vers la présidentielle l'élection
présidentielle de 2012 en toute état de
cause sera
extraordinairement difficile je sais qui
est ma candidate c'est Eva Joly
Centre en France a le droit et le devoir
d'être présent dans cette élection il
faut faire ce que Marine Le Pen a dit en
partenariat avec Radio Classique en
route vers la présidentielle tous les
matins à 8h15 en direct sur Public Sénat
chaque année 70 000 personnes sont
hospitalisées sans leur consentement
alors que la loi qui encadre ses
hospitalisations vient d'être réformées
la réalisatrice Lorraine de Baisieux a
enquêté sur le monde de la psychiatrie
j'avais envie de parler d'un sujet qui
me semble encore très tabou je pense que
la folie fait peur encore aujourd'hui et
que j'avais envie de parler des
fractures de la société ça en fait
partie et je pense que c'est une manière
de d'écrire la société que de raconter
comment la société traite ses fous c'est
un enjeu important c'est une façon aussi
de voir quel est le niveau d'une société
exactement de voir comment elle gère à
la marge les personnes qui sont pas dans
le circuit de communes
c'est un enjeu important parce que il y
a à peu près 70 000 personnes qui sont
hospitalisées sous contrainte par an et
que ça correspond à peu près au nombre
de personnes qui sont incarcérées
équivalent donc c'est vrai que c'est
comparable l'enjeu est important et
voilà il nous semblait important de
donner la parole aux personnes
concernées
d'un enfant comme ça qu'on demande à
hospitaliser c'est quoi c'est la
trahison qu'on semble lui faire c'est la
peur de se tromper c'est quoi là j'avais
pas peur de me tromper de toute façon je
suis pas toute seule dans le gars c'est
une mère ne veut pas hospitaliser son
enfant de force il y a pas la vie du
psychiatre donc il y a des médecins qui
vous appuient ou qui vous qui disent non
ou qui disent oui mais il y a pas que
vous vous le demandez mais bon ce qui
est c'est vous voyez votre enfant partir
dans une ambulance en ayant une piqûre
calmante de force dans la fesse voilà il
vous suivez vous arrivez en pleine nuit
dans un hôpital
psychiatrique que ça soit Sainte Anne ou
polyguero d'autres c'est quand même un
peu style asile du XIXe siècle donc
voilà ma fille me disait tu m'as fait
interner chez les fous non je t'ai fait
hospitaliser
parce que tu es malade et tu as besoin
c'est terrible pour pour avoir la
confiance après récupérer elle peut elle
comprend pas elle veut pas et puis petit
à petit petit à petit il y a quand même
une espèce de compréhension que ça n'est
pas vraiment pour lui faire du mal et
que elle y trouve aussi elle a fait la
démarche elle-même parfois d'y aller
seul dimanche
c'est une évolution dans son traitement
et dans son état et donc elle a admis
qu'au fil du temps que vous ayez fait le
bon choix que d'appeler des médecins
pour la contraindre à se faire soigner
c'est ça en gros c'est ça oui
concrètement comment ça se passe quand
on rentre comme ça hospitalisé le monde
d'un tiers ou d'office dans un hôpital
on n'est pas libre on est enfermé on est
contraint on est attaché on a quand même
dans une chambre et quoi on est avant
tout protégé
mais dans toute la médecine il y a des
mesures qui sont prises quand on reçoit
quelqu'un qui est à moitié dans le coma
on va on va on va prendre toutes les
dispositions pour qu'il se fasse pas de
mal en tombant nous nous devons faire en
sorte que puisqu'il n'est pas conscient
des troubles dont il souffre que il ne
quitte pas l'hôpital immédiatement qu'il
ne se fasse pas du mal qu'il ne fasse
pas de mal à d'autres patients enfin
c'est toutes ces mesures de carcération
mais on est on est quand même dans une
logique de privation de contraintes on
peut donner un traitement à quelqu'un
qu'il refuse on peut le voir à tous les
usages et toutes les règles on peut le
voir sur ce regard là mais pour
l'instant crédit que c'est une
protection
nécessaire et et qui n'est pas
discutable l'arrivée du juge c'est c'est
très très difficile à vivre pour les
psychiatres qui jusqu'à présent était un
peu maître chez eux et qui sont
maintenant obligés effectivement de
justifier encore une fois la privation
liberté nous avons eu de longs débat
l'Assemblée pour savoir si le juge
devait aussi intervenir dans
l'obligation de soins et il nous est
apparu nous député toute tendance
politique confondue l'obligation de soi
à domicile à l'extérieur à l'extérieur
qui est une nouveauté de la loi aussi
indépendamment obligé les soins mais là
il y a pas le regard du juge pour
l'instant voilà de la privation de
liberté il nous a semblé que le juge
n'avait pas intervenir sur l'obligation
de soi ça c'est le rôle du médecin c'est
le rôle du psychiatre à côté de ça la
notion de privation de liberté elle est
fondamentale et ça ce n'est pas du
ressort du médecin c'est vraiment du
ressort du juge de la liberté alors
savoir si
est en mesure ou pas de sortir alors ça
se passe plus ou moins bien selon que
les juges se déplacent à l'hôpital ou
pas nous avons aujourd'hui dans les
auditions que nous avons menées le
premier bilan montre qu'environ 30% des
juges se déplacent dans les hôpitaux et
dans ce cas là ça se passe globalement
très bien est-ce qu'ils comprennent bien
que vous êtes de leur côté pas en face
et comment ça se passe qui sont véhément
à ce qui c'est ce qui revendique
il y a toute une un certain nombre de
patients qui comprennent